yeah let's jump into this first story
man this crazy stuff we got this from
timcast.com breaking shelter in place
issued in Tucson Arizona following
hazardous material leak on I-10
civilians within a one mile radius have
been ordered to evacuate the stretch of
road has reportedly been closed in both
directions at milepost 272. civilians
within a one mile radius have been
ordered to evacuate the Arizona
Department of Transportation has not
issued an estimated time for i-10's
reopening as of this report a report's
publication we have this video from
alerts is that you say it let's see if
we can uh we can play this take a look
at this let me get the uh audio going
for you guys there we go
thank you
so I don't know what that yellow stuff
spraying out of there is but I certainly
wouldn't want to be anywhere near it
so there it is I mean simply put they
say Tucson's National Weather Service
cautioned drivers of dense blowing dust
prior to the trucks overturning
motorists traveling along I-10 should be
prepared for rapidly reduced visibility
below a mile to blowing dust images and
video from the incident show what
appears to be yellow and red smoke
emitting from the overturned truck which
is reportedly carrying nitric acid
according to Pima County's office of
emergency management and Tucson fire
this seems like it may just be an
accident and accidents happen so my
question for you guys I'm wondering is
it because of what's happening in Ohio
we are now laser focused on things like
this that we probably shouldn't be that
worried about or I mean or or is there
another reason we typically I'll put it
this way
we usually don't hear big news about if
one mile evacuation orders and shelter
in place orders I mean that I feel like
that'd be big news no matter what
whenever it would happen but maybe we
just don't care so they never it never
makes Twitter it never makes the news I
think that I think you're probably right
that it it's uh people kind of focusing
on this stuff because of the the
situation in Ohio
um I think that Ohio is dramatic uh it's
clearly something that the the the EPA
and transportation TSA are not the uh
yeah
and TSB or whatever like or they should
be paying attention to that I think that
this this situation in in Tucson is
likely just an accident you know
unfortunately but we don't hear stories
like this I mean I kind of feel like if
there was a one mile radius evacuation
I feel like if that were to happen at
any other time we'd be talking about it
I think only be I think the only reason
that I do that I think so personally I
feel like it's hard to go down the uh
the rabbit hole not hard to not go down
the rabbit hole it's do we believe in
coincidences maybe things like this
happen all the time but it seems a
little suspiciously close to it I mean
you can't help but wonder and then it
also seems concerning because you know
we mentioned mayor Pete who had that big
press conference but failed to mention
what I've seen people talking about as
the worst man-made disaster that ever
happened on American soil is what's
happening now in Ohio in Ohio yeah and
we're like two hours away from there we
are not very far from that at all that's
creepy definitely in that radius Tucker
Carlson suggested we're under attack
let's say we were under attack I mean
but you look at what's going so for one
thing I I think it's fair to say it's a
fact that the power Grid's being
attacked we've got numerous reports of
extremists I guess whether you believe
it or not but numerous reports of some
kind of extremists shooting at power
substations and knocking electricity out
so like that's happening yeah but then
you've got I mean I don't know how you
look you've got the toxic chemical spill
you've got the balloons in our air the
objects floating in our airspace
interfering with with civilian
commercial airlines
and uh yeah I don't know I can't help
but feel like our infrastructure is
being attacked you've got food shortages
in certain areas eggs specifically but
then you look at the culling of chickens
and and this is what this is the
messaging we got when when we talked
about it people were like you keep
blaming Joe Biden for the cost of eggs
but you're not telling people people
about the avian flu that's sweeping
through the chicken populations and I'm
like oh yeah like in New Zealand and
South Africa where they're calling
chickens too why are they calling
chickens different reasons for some
reason everybody's culling chickens in
different countries maybe just a big
coincidence
or I don't know maybe there's something
else going on Mike dewine the governor
of Ohio did this press conference today
where he said that the train that was
passing through the state authorities
weren't notified of what it was carrying
because it wasn't considered a high
hazardous material train and that means
like that there weren't enough chemicals
on it for it to be considered dangerous
from the explanation the governor gave
and that makes me think that this this
must happen more often than we realize
and this one just kind of blew up on
social media I mean if you saw the
videos of the trains on fire there was
no way you could look away and then on
top of that they followed up with a
controlled burn that looked like
essentially Chernobyl I mean that's what
people are cautious of right have you
guys ever seen Aaron Brockovich yeah I
mean this stuff happens you know what
was it what was that story like they
were polluting the groundwater and then
people were drinking chromium or
something yeah hex surveillance chromium
or something like that it was killing
them all yeah so is it that it doesn't
is it that we're noticing that it
happened in Ohio and then it happened in
South Carolina and then it happened in
Houston and now it didn't happen in
South Carolina and I don't believe it
happened in Houston but I don't know you
were reading something earlier so what
happens is you get a train that derails
in Ohio and a mushroom cloud and a
controlled burn animals are dying and
then the next time a train derails
everyone's like it's happening again but
it's like yo trains derail like all the
time yeah like
112 or 150 per month yeah over a
thousand people with the number of that
of trained derailments that apparently
happen all the time this one or at least
the one in Ohio seems a little bit
aggressive because again the mushroom
cloud you could see from space so
something there seems a little bit
different plus we were looking at the
report earlier that said there may have
been more poisonous chemicals in that
than we originally thought somebody's
lying somebody is lying I don't know who
it is but somebody is lying and Pete
today said we've done you know the
majority of testings and I think it's
like 200 and however many of 400 homes
and uh there's been no detection there's
no detection of of what chemicals like
what are you telling us he's saying that
everything's okay 10 days after the fact
right shouldn't he have been there by
now shouldn't we have heard more about
this I don't believe a word he says and
I don't think that he has any you know
it doesn't matter what he says because I
don't even if even if I believed what he
says I would be I think like even if
he's telling the truth or he believes
he's telling the truth I don't think
that they they have accurate information
I don't think that they they have the
that's really I guess what it boils down
to I don't think that they have accurate
information to give to people I think
that they're spitballing and guessing
err on the side of caution yeah I
remember I was in downtown Chicago a
couple decades ago riding my bike and
then I saw smoke coming out of like the
10th floor of a building and I see
people walking up to the building and
they're like going like this and they're
looking at it and you know what I did I
went the other way I'm like yo if
there's some kind of leak or who knows
what's going on why are you walking
towards it well I want to sue you or
something like that what is it what is
it called uh rubbernecking yeah sticking
your neck out and trying to go look at
something and uh man it's kind of crazy
because I've just all always known that
lesson I guess my dad taught me that he
was a firefighter it's like you see
smoke you get the away from it yeah but
regular people they go towards it and
you think that like that was like it was
really dramatic the the burn in in Ohio
it's not like you know everyone here
agrees that it looked something like a
mushroom cloud or like an actual volcano
erupting like go the other way and
anyone yeah anyone that can get out of
there it's probably a good idea to leave
I can't imagine that but you know but
what if you can't go in well that's a
different story I mean so so here's
here's the question here's the question
I got you know you can't ignore it right
I mean what's going on in Arizona people
are posting videos of it maybe this
stuff happens way more than people
realize it is really really bad but
nobody knows or cares right so it's kind
of like uh that there's that experiment
they did where they took a guy and they
put him in a room and they said you know
we're going to have you do be part of a
study just fill out this paperwork while
he's filling out the paperwork they blow
smoke under the door the dude then gets
up and goes to the door and feels see if
it's hot and then yells hey there's
smoke there's smoke in here and then he
goes and opens and calls some people in
they then do another trial
same thing they tell some people you're
going to be in an experiment come in
this room and felt this paperwork they
put three people in the room have them
all sit down start filling out paperwork
blow smoke under the door and you know
what the people do then see the smoke
look at everybody else look at the smoke
look at everybody else go back to
filling out that paperwork the bystander
effect is really yeah hey if nobody's
out I'm not gonna and then there was
another really funny experiment uh I
can't remember what show this was they
have people go into like a doctor's
office and then they're sitting down and
then one by one people come in and sit
down and then a bell rings and every
time it does all of the actors stand up
and then the bell rings and they sit
down and the person who's like not in on
it is confused it's like what's going on
then eventually joins in and starts
doing the same standing up and sitting
down it's like why would you do that
it's the craziest thing people do not
think independently and that's dangerous
so here's what I'm saying with this
Arizona stuff I bet this stuff happens
all the time and they never have to
report on it because nobody cares but
now because of Ohio somebody sees an
orange gas coming out and they post it
on Twitter everybody posts it then
they're forced to say okay evacuate when
you should have evacuated in the first
place but they didn't want to say
anything because it would freak people
out and make them look bad yeah
I mean do we think that there's maybe a
hyper fixation on these events that
happen afterwards because they want to
lessen the attention that's happening on
higher well it's well it happens
increases the attention
like this I mean like like here we are
second night you know starting a show
off talking about toxic chemical spills
because of this and people are scared
now that the derailment in South
Carolina and Houston were toxic chemical
spills but as far as I can tell they
weren't I think there was like something
with Houston where they're like
concerned about a potential leak but
there's no real you know there's no like
smoke going anywhere or anything like
that whereas with Ohio there's a
gigantic black cloud filling the sky and
animals are dying and stuff like that so
I'm just saying the government probably
wouldn't warn you if they don't have to
warn you yup that means for all you know
you could go outside and be walking into
a cloud of radioactive garbage and
they're like just don't say anything
otherwise we'll look bad
you can trust the government to do that
I guess you can absolutely trust the
government to try and hide things
absolutely a number of trained Romans or
trained collisions happen in extremely
rural areas right where it's easy to say
it didn't happen I mean one of the big
things with all of this is uh social
media right people filmed these things
happening they definitely definitely
filmed uh the fire they definitely
filmed the explosion it makes people
more aware of keeping an eye out for
this but if you're in the middle of a
cornfield and your train topples over
even if it doesn't have chemicals on it
you know really it's up to the companies
involved Amtrak in this case Norfolk
Southern to say something and why would
they if they don't need to we got a
super chat from ca2ca Outdoors that says
Tim per the NFPA they were 433 500
hazardous material incidents last year I
think it's laser focus on an incident uh
it's on a huge scale
um yeah but here's the thing about
hazardous material incidents
that could mean like someone in an
airport spilled a bottle of um of
acetone and then it's like ah we got an
Aston spill like ah all right we gotta
get this cleaned up fill out the
paperwork and there's like a puddle on
the ground but you can't drive through
it you can't put equipment through it so
they got to get it clean somehow things
like that where it's like nobody's gonna
die because someone spilled a gallon of
acetone if someone suck if someone
vomits on a plane they consider that
that a Hazmat right because it's you
know yeah biohazard yeah I don't know
are all these events going into the same
file folder at the office you know yeah
mushroom cloud from that you can see
from space somebody threw up on an
airplane and somebody mentioned too in
the chat that nitric acid will basically
put you out if you breathe it in so
don't get anywhere near that stuff and
there are people driving through this
Cloud thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time